I have never had a feeling as pure a
proud as completing a mission all you
everything we've done in the last 17
years trying to make a difference and we
never took it done you've been shot five
times for your country and you can't
even afford to send your kids to college
I got a job for you I'm retired
fish I need a pilot I get the baby now
this can change you in that baby's life
forever we finally get to use our skills
for our own benefit all right let's do
it
[Music]
we're gonna get Gabrielle Martina Raya
head of one of the biggest drug cartels
I've got estimates he's got over 75
million dollars in cash if we're not
gone forever after you make your move or
you're dead
you cannot go back to your normal life
after tonight you guys need to own the
fact what we're about to do is criminal
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] regards their back we got to go all
right we can use take a backpack of cash
and we're gone no there's about a
hundred million dollars wait in the van
out there we are not leaving them any of
this funny what kills where it is here
we need to hunt quickly that's not what
I signed up for times though
Hey
some of the future back in there we go a
message like that
as money a lot more people are gonna
come after you you lied to us
thank God every town covered so we go
through them
a little hard and you think it's going
to be
it's too late to walk away
[Music]
you
you